the unity brings all three boxes
together in perfect sync
its power builds until it can't be
contained if I can cause a delay between
each box even for a nanosecond its
energy will cascade form a loop I feed
on each other and that's it we just pull
them apart no fuss no muss separating
the box is still gonna cause a massive
surge I have to be there but you guys
should think about getting clear
we're with you dude it's done honestly I
think we're all gonna be dead way before
that hey you know what I don't mind it's
an honorable end but we gotta shut
Steppenwolf down Superman's a no-show
you got no powers no offense this guy
might be working for the enemy we don't
know you're tripping over your feet and
mine poof you're gorgeous
and fierce and strong hmm I know we went
to war with the Amazons but I was before
my time hey you know what I don't want
to die I'm young they're [ __ ] that I
want to do I feel like I never really
embraced sea or the land I've been alone
my whole life being part of something
bigger like this maybe I'm scared
because I meant
I think that was beautiful
you say a word about this we'll meet
every pronoun I know I honestly didn't
hear anything after we're all gonna die
you